my name is Cristina Sanders my name is
Christopher Sanders about buddy
we've been married 14 years and we have
11 children if you didn't live here you
would not think that this was possible I
[Music]
would describe our house as organized
chaos let's go boys there's never a dull
moment in the Sanders home we are busy
all day every day from the time we wake
up to the time we go to bed we're doing
something the kids would love to take
long hot showers but there are so many
of them that's just not a reality for we
definitely got a brother that takes the
longest it's not brother Kaden yes
sometimes I do get yelled at for taking
long shot we are getting ready to do a
chore list the chores are very important
in the sadness household we have a chore
chart two children per chore
Haley and Kristen there are so many of
us something has always get dirty
because we pretty much utilize every
inch of the house me and Chris always
wanted a big family
after having five biological children I
knew that I wanted to have more children
that's when we decided to become foster
parents we got the call Sam they had
four boys and they were like we're on
our way right now and I said okay hope
you hear over ORMs after the children's
first night here that's when I found out
they had two sisters we knew right away
that we wanted to foster them because
it's important for the siblings to stay
together I was just feeling a little
nervous about how they were except me
not knowing if they had any interaction
with a man of my color and size you know
a big black guy so I was just like
hoping that they would embrace me but
love has no color love has no boundaries
and so on April 27 2017 we adopted all
six children and they officially became
Santa's children like having another
baby
this big that was
[Music]
the secret of rays and happy children is
I think happy parents everything is not
so serious just relax you know you can't
mess up sometimes it's okay it's not
easy with a large family like this but
in the end it's all worth it it's all
worth it good night
[Music]